i'm not going to do an integration uh by
parts problem that i think is just it's
just a fun problem to see because uh
one it's kind of the example a lot of
people use and sometimes even a trick
problem that's given on a you know a
really hard math exam or or if you go to
calculus competitions like like i used
to in high school
not to make myself too i was actually
not that geeky as a high school student
but i i have to admit i i i was a math
lead but anyway
this is just a fun integration by parts
problems because
you actually never have to evaluate
kind of the final integral
so let's say we want to take the
integral it's a bit of a classic you'll
you'll see this you're i wouldn't be
surprised if your math teacher
does the same problem for you just to
show you integration by parts let's take
the integral of e to the x you probably
never heard of someone call a math
problem a classic but but hopefully you
you i will instill in you this love for
mathematics and you will also consider
this to be a classic problem
e to the x times cosine of x
i think you might already see where i'm
going with this right because these are
both fun functions because e to the x
you can take the derivative you could
take the anti-derivative and it still
stays e to the x cosine of x
you take the derivative you go to minus
sine of x and you take the derivative
again then you get to minus cosine of x
and you take the derivative again then
you get a plus sign of x right so it's
like the cycle and the same thing
happens when you take the antiderivative
it's not as cool as e to the x it
doesn't stay exactly the same but it
kind of cycles every time you take a
antiderive if you take two
anti-derivatives you get back to the
negative of itself and if you take two
derivatives you get back to the negative
of itself so it's pretty it's it's it's
also a pretty cool function and i i
think you can start to see where how
integration by parts might be might be
cool here
so i whenever i do integration by parts
i always like to assume that this is the
g prime of x that e to the x is g prime
of x right because e to the x literally
doesn't change although
we we could we could do this problem the
other way actually maybe i'll i'll
experiment doing it the other way but
let's assume this is g prime of x and
let's assume this is f of x
right it says g prime so this is the
derivative so integration by part says
we take the original functions g of x
and f of x so f so g of x if this is g
prime of x what's g of x what's the
anti-derivative of e to the x
right it's it's just e to the x i'm
gonna switch colors i don't like this
blue
so this is
this is
g
of x right i actually took the
anti-derivative of it but it's the same
exact thing
and then times
f of x
and then i want to subtract
the integral
the indefinite integral
of
f prime of x well well
one
g of x right
g of x this is the same as this which
are both the anti-derivative of this
although they're all the same
so this is g prime of x i mean this is g
of x sorry and then i want to take the
derivative of f of x f prime of x so
what's the derivative of cosine of x
it's minus sine of x
so sine of x
dx and it's minus sine of x right so i
could put the minus here that'll make it
look messy i could put the minus j
that'll make it messy or i could just
say put a minus here make these minuses
cancel out and i get a plus here
so i get the integral of e to the x
cosine of x dx is equal to e to the x
cosine of x plus the integral of e to
the x sine of x dx right
hopefully i haven't confused you too
much i should actually probably do some
integration by parts problems without
edx because it's very hard to keep track
of what what i've done here i've
actually this is the antiderivative
and i
this is the anti-derivative and this is
also the anti-derivative this is g prime
of x this is g of x
this is g of x
so once again we're we i'm not clear
whether we've made any progress you know
we've gone from e to the x cosine of x
to e to the x sine of x let's take
integration by parts again see let's see
what happens
so let me i'm just going to write on the
right side of the equal sign because
this might get a little long
so this equals so i'm just going to
write this
first part e to the x
cosine of x
plus
and now let's do integration by parts
again
so once again now now in this this round
of integration by parts let's
you know for this round of integration
by parts this was g of x but now for
this round i'm going to assume it's g
prime of x
which doesn't really make a difference
because when i take the antiderivative
of it to g of x it stays the same and
then i'm assuming that this is f of x
right so integration by parts tells us
we take
f of x times g of x right so i take this
function and the anti-derivative of this
function
well the anti-derivative of this
function is once again just e to the x
and then f times that function unchanged
right times sine of x
and then from that i subtract
the integral
of the antiderivative of this right or i
take of g of x which is e to the x
and then the derivative of f of x right
f prime of x what's the derivative of
sine of x well it's cosine of x
cosine of x d of x
let's see if we're getting anywhere it
seems like i'm just
keep adding terms and making it more and
more complicated so
in order to see if we're getting
anywhere let me just rewrite the whole
thing and and maybe get rid of these
parentheses because it's just a plus so
we can actually get rid of the
parentheses so i have
let me use
let me use uh
i want a new color okay so this is the
original problem
e to the x
cosine of x
dx
equals
and then let me switch back to this
color it equals e to the x
cosine
of x
and then i can just this parenthesis
doesn't matter right because i'm just
adding everything in the parentheses e
to the x cosine of x
plus
e to the x
sine of x
minus
e to the x
cosine of x
dx
now you might think that i arbitrarily
switched colors here but i'm right when
i rewrote this but if you look you might
see why i actually did switch colors
here
see anything interesting
exactly
this is the same thing as this just a
minus right so we're going to do
something what i think to be fairly cool
let's take let's add
this term to both sides of the equation
right let's take this and let's put it
onto this side of the equation well if i
take this and put on this side of the
equation what happens
i then have two of these on the left
side of the equation so that becomes
i mean i could write it out that's e to
the you know this it's
e to the x cosine of x
dx plus right because i'm taking this
and i'm putting on that side of the
equation
e to the x
cosine
of x dx right and that's just the same
thing as
2 times the integral of e to the x
cosine of x dx
and then that equals this term
which equals and i'm running out of
space
e to the x
cosine of x
plus e to the x sine of x i know it's
really messy but all i have to do now to
solve this integral is divide both sides
by 2 and i'm done
right so let me write it out it's very
exciting where it's the home stretch
so if i just divide both sides by 2 i
get and i'm going to try to write it so
you can see everything
e to the x
cosine of x
dx
equals
and on that side
i have
e to the x
cosine of x
plus
e to the x
sine of x
over 2. i think that's pretty neat i
think it's it's it's a neat how
integration by parts kind of allowed us
to do this we actually never even had to
evaluate this integral we said oh well
this integral is just the original
problem again and you can think about
why that happened right because because
these trig functions cycle so we have to
do integration by parts twice to kind of
get back to where we were before
and then um we you know we use that to
kind of just um
solve it uh without actually having to
evaluate the integral and what i also
think is cool is that even if you just
look at this
solution it's it's kind of neat right
the antiderivative of e to the x oh and
i i should never forget the plus c that
would have given me like minus one point
on the exam but
what's kind of cool the integral of e to
the x cosine of x is this is this
expression that's you know e to the x
cosine of x plus e to the x sine of x
divided by 2. it's the average it's the
average of e to the x cosine of x and e
to the x sine of x i think that's that's
that's that's a pretty neat property and
you might want to graph them and and
play with them but it it it's kind of
neat um
i hopefully i i have convinced you that
this is a classic of a problem and you
also find it neat
and i'll i'll see you in the next
presentation